hey guys it's just Eid and wow wow wow
you guys have been tweeting me images of
what potentially could be the next
iPhone there's been so many rumors
already and it's not even time for this
phone to even be remotely announced but
who knows anything can happen but the
iPhone whatever the next version of the
iPhone will be called is right now we're
calling it the iPhone 11 which I guess
in theory would technically be a good
name for the next phone I don't know do
you know
does anybody know just Apple nope have
they actually thought of a name yet
either way I thought that we would just
kind of do a quick little roundup and
just go through and see some of the
things that people are reportedly ruling
don't worry it's gonna be a while before
this vote actually comes out the first
rumor and something that I've been
hoping for in the last few phones is
that Apple would get rid of a lightning
cable and switch all the USBC and I
think it's only a matter of time because
the latest iPad is USBC their Mac books
or USBC and their iPhones are not it
drives me crazy I just am so sick of
having so many different cables and
honestly don't even get me started on
air power
it was definitely supposed to be
something that was like last year I
still have high hopes for it one of the
biggest struggles is charging my phone
charging my watch
charging my air pod I still keep hoping
that one day Apple just surprises us
with a lovely gift of surprise it's here
the thing that I don't like about this
is it says that a more recent report
claimed that the iPhone 11 phones will
have lightning ports
I don't like that this is not a change
that we can expect to see this year I
think they're gonna do it I think
they're gonna do it I don't know I have
no idea I'm not sure fingers crossed
again I've been crossing them for three
years at this point
reports that Apple's next-gen phone will
support faster Wi-Fi support for 5g this
is pretty great because the original
iPhone didn't even chip with 3G it's a
gamble a few years to support 4G new
iPhone 11 camera leaked super selfies
and triple rear camera setup if they're
gonna do the triple camera it's
definitely an interesting look it's very
similar to the huawei mate 20 a pro
phone and I don't know it's just like a
thing it's just it's just I don't know
whose video is this
was everything Apple pros hello friend
what are you saying I leave for a couple
weeks and I come back and I don't
understand Apple ad
wait that's kind of my same thought too
I was gone traveling for the holidays
and I you hop back on Twitter and I look
up Apple rumors and it's just like what
has happened they came out with charging
cases the rumors of 500 cameras in the
back this is realistically what I would
like the next iPhone to look like tally
the oval is gold that gold phone looks
really really good so if we do want to
go with this 3 camera setup I mean can
we just like put them all three in a
line here just like that I just don't
know I don't even know I'm making this
video and I'm just getting super
confused I've got my feelings like I
don't know what I like like what are you
what is this
Oh like what are you doing what is this
what actually what I was just thinking
about is the third camera this is also
interesting putting this in the center
like that it's a very I mean it seems
like putting the camera in the center is
a very common thing in most phones so
it's really not that absurd look at that
that's just that's a look that's
something like how many freaking one two
that's four there's four four freaking
cameras do we need any more we do Oh
what's this what are you the same exact
thing but the cameras are moved over I
don't know what to think I don't know
what to feel
I mean what are you what are you that's
more along the lines of something that I
was thinking I definitely think one of
the things that I have hopes for in the
future of the next iPhone is a better
front-facing camera I would love love
love love to see it finally before K
because I do film a lot of my videos on
my phone and what I'm swishing from the
front into the back it doesn't make that
huge of a difference but when you are
shooting all 4k content and then you mix
in front-facing footage from your phone
that's sort of where you see the huge
difference so it will be really exciting
to see what they do with that because I
think improving the front-facing camera
is definitely a huge step forward so
anyway these are some of the run
that I've seen and I'm like I don't know
man
I don't know what's it gonna be also
something that's interesting is the hole
punch design for front-facing cameras I
don't know if I'm a huge fan of it it's
like where are you gonna put it I do
like the concept of the sliding a
flip-up front-facing camera it's like
that's kind of cool because it is a way
that you can have an old screen front
and not have to worry about where you're
gonna put the front-facing camera I
can't really see Apple doing that but I
feel like at some point they are gonna
have to do something super drastic super
crazy where people are like you did what
oh you remove the headphone jack which
I'm still a fan of I totally do not miss
the headphone jack at all I'm earpods I
have so many various and wireless
headphones that at this point the only
time that I ever need wired headphones
is when I'm out shooting and I need to
monitor audio so that's basically it but
other than that those are some of the
phones that I've seen so I also want to
say a huge shout out to a bunch of the
artists who have rendered these things
too because you guys are super talented
and I think it's incredible to see the
way that people perceive things that
they want to see in the future be sure
to leave me some comments below and let
me know what you think the next iPhone
will have what will the next iPhone be
named I don't think it's gonna be called
the iPhone 11 for some reason but I'm
not sure a zero in sight I don't know
anything
I am purely sitting here on my computer
googling things all of the things that I
have seen here you guys also have access
to I'm just kind of curating it so this
is not secret information it's freaking
Google I'll see you guys in my next
video also I've been enjoying this
battery case a lot more than I thought
okay see you guys later
I'm gonna go edit this video note
you